Welcome back to our next episode of
What's Up, Prof? Hello, Walter. Hi.
I was thinking, how are you coping with
all the opposition that we have been
getting in the last 3 months?
Well, yes.
Uh we do have opposition, but you know,
I had a very encouraging talk to
someone who is an a pilot.
And he told me that when the wind is
from the front, then the airplane gets
more lift.
And we want to go to a higher plane, so
lift is a good thing. Amen. Yes.
So, I also see that we've got some new
decorations on the table. No, they're
actually old decorations. They were in
the back here. So, there's been a swap.
This is a beautiful ammonite. I don't
know whether you can see it.
I don't know how I should lift it up and
to whom I should lift it up, but uh
it's a gorgeous fossil, and it's not
millions of years old
because mineralization like this can
take place within a very short period of
time.
And there are many, many cases of that.
So,
this very young fossil, which is
supposedly millions of years old, is a
nice example of what we've been speaking
about, a young earth. A young earth.
Then, there's another question that I
would quickly want us to handle before
we go into um
today's like uh discussion.
And that is
also on the age of the the earth and so
on. Just quick, the oil fields.
Some people say that that also
can it happen in a quick Oh, absolutely.
Uh there are cases of rapid oil
formation. Now, what is oil? It's
organic material.
So, it's microorganisms
and
dead organic material that has been
covered in the flood
and then turned into oil. And basically,
it is uh
material of living organisms that have
decayed to become oil. And it can happen
very, very rapidly. For example,
coal formation is very similar.
Uh you know that you can make oil from
coal.
And uh
if you take the the ancient fence posts
that they erected in, let's say, United
States of America or other places, some
of these posts have actually turned to
coal in the bottom, and that's not
millions of years. Now, we're talking
since colonization. So, that is very
rapid, yes.
Oh, thank you. And then, just before we
go on, I just want to explain to the
viewers, especially that on the YouTube,
the links that we provide, that we
always refer to,
if you go underneath
the description, there is a button that
says show more,
and all the links are provided there.
Also, we So, in other words, under the
picture of the video that's actually
running, there is a description of what
we're talking about, and there is a
little link which says show more.
A button. A button.
Yes. Okay.
If you click that show more button, then
you'll get the links that we refer to in
there. Also there, you'll get contact
details if you want to send questions to
um to us at Amazing Discoveries Africa.
And then also, just underneath that,
the we usually pin all the links in the
first comment underneath the the um
video. And you also have to go to the
button that says show more. So, that's
just to clarify it for some people if
you have difficulty finding the links.
Will you open for us in prayer?
Absolutely.
Our loving heavenly Father, today we are
going to discuss
the difference between the religion of
Babylon
and the religion of the Bible.
And we need heavenly wisdom to
understand all its ramifications.
And so, we ask for the presence of your
spirit in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
So, what are we going to talk about
today? Well, today we're going to talk
about Babylon.
And we're going to talk about
the loud cry message,
which is the call of the the fourth
angel of Revelation 18.
Uh we did discuss, you know, all the
events that are taking place, and we
have very interesting things happening
at the moment with the World Monetary
Fund and the
all of the reset that they want to have
in place with the economies and the
social relationships of of uh humanity
and the nations. And you have this
tremendous globalization push on the one
hand, and then the contrast of the
nationalistic push from the Trump team
on the other hand, and you have this
interesting Hegelian dialectic going on.
But we we will do that another time.
Uh I was very interested to see what he
actually said at his Tulsa speech
uh recently, and
that was very obviously a clash between
globalism and nationalism.
Yes. And uh what Prince Charles had to
say on the other side of the spectrum,
but uh that is a discussion for
something else.
But why are we going to talk about
Babylon?
Because, you know, the Bible is so clear
that we have to flee from Babylon just
before
Christ is coming.
And if we have to flee from Babylon, why
must we flee from Babylon?
And the question, of course, is
paramount, who is Babylon?
And so, we need to have a look at the
issues as to why
an organization can be part of Babylon
in the times that we are living in.
So, if we can go to some of the slides
that we've prepared,
uh
you can see the title is Babylon and the
doctrine of the serpent.
Now, what is the doctrine of the
serpent? The doctrine of the serpent is
made clear in the very first chapters of
Genesis. And in
chapter 3 verse 1 of the book of
Genesis,
we have the serpent saying, "And he said
unto the woman, Yea, has God said?"
In other words, he's saying, "Did God
really say that?"
Uh "Are you sure God said that? I'm sure
he didn't mean that. He must have meant
something else, right?"
And then he negates what God said, and
he presents a counter theology.
And that's the doctrine of the serpent.
And if we analyze those issues, then we
know what the the theology of Babylon is
all about and why it should be avoided.
So, it's very important that we we look
into those issues, especially in the
time where we are living,
where this loud cry will go to the world
very shortly.
"So, did God really say?" is a very
important part of
of the Bible.
Genesis chapter 3, let's look at that
verse in a little bit more detail. Now,
the serpent was more subtle.
Mm, that's a very important word, right?
Yeah. Very descriptive word. He's
subtle. Can it be linked to also to
sneaky? Sneaky, absolutely, yes.
Subtle than any beast of the field which
the Lord God had made. And he said unto
the woman, "Yea, has God said, Ye shall
not eat of every tree of the garden?"
They went to eat of this one particular
tree.
There was so much food there. And if we
go a little bit back and see what the
diet of man was,
then we can ask the question, "Did God
really say that all the creatures ate
plants?"
In Genesis 1 verse 29, God said,
"Behold, I have given you every herb
bearing seed,
which is upon the face of all the earth,
and every tree in which is the fruit of
a tree yielding seed, to you it shall be
for meat." In other words, for food.
So, the original diet, as we have seen,
is every herb bearing seed. So, those
are all the seed plants. It's all the
grains, all the seeds.
Uh
every tree with fruit on it. That's all
the fruit trees and the nut trees and
all of these.
And that was the original food of man,
and the original food and diet of the of
the beasts of the earth, and all the
fowls of the air, and everything that
creeps upon the earth wherein there is
life I've given every green herb for
meat for food and it was so.
So everything on the planet was
vegetarian.
Now we've discussed some of these issues
before we don't have to go into it but
the question I'm asking is in today's
context
do people really believe that everything
was vegetarian?
Or do they think evolutionary and think
that animals evolved and obviously a
carnivore
in evolutionary thinking has an
advantage over a herbivore because he
has to develop strategies to catch
animals etc. etc. So that eventually led
to higher and higher intelligence.
The other question did God really say
that there was only one way by which
atonement could be secured?
In other words was there only one way of
salvation?
Because we have so many religions in the
world and they all have different modes
of salvation.
So did God really say that there was
only one way?
In Genesis chapter 4 verse 4 we read and
Abel
he also brought of the firstlings of his
flock and of the fat thereof and the
Lord had respect unto Abel and unto his
offering.
But unto Cain and to his offering he had
not respect.
And Cain was very wroth and his
countenance fell.
So the one that Abel brought was
acceptable. God had respect unto Abel's
offering.
Because he followed the guidelines. He
had to bring a lamb and if we go back
into the Bible and we come to a future
event where John the Baptist says behold
the lamb of God
that taketh away the sins of the world.
It was of course a type this firstling
of the flock of Jesus Christ and that is
the way so to salvation. There is no
other name under heaven whereby we may
be saved except the name Christ Jesus.
That is a biblical
criterion.
But Cain said no, I will bring the works
of my hands. I will not follow this
atonement path. So it seems that from
the very beginning there is conflict
about the way in which we are saved.
And the Bible is very clear right from
the book of Genesis all the way through
to the book of Revelation
that it is the lamb of God that brings
salvation to the earth and there is no
other way in which you can be saved.
There's no other name under heaven
whereby you may be saved. So
Cain's offering
was not acceptable. But what was Cain's
attitude when he's offering his own
works when they were not accepted?
He was very wroth.
And his countenance fell. So obviously
there is conflict
even until today in terms of how are we
saved? This is important.
And the way of Cain eventually led to
the way of Babylon.
So the the mode this operandi of Babylon
in terms of the plan of salvation
is salvation by your own works.
And the plan of the Bible is salvation
by the lamb of God.
Another question that arises is did God
really say that there would be a day of
judgment for the antediluvian world?
So obviously there is a test, right?
And man is
judged according to his activities.
So this choice is not just a haphazard
choice.
Didn't you give a sermon on little
things?
Did God really say that you should not
eat of the fruit of this tree? You said
that was a little thing but look at the
big consequences that it had.
So even though God is long-suffering
eventually there's a judgment.
So in Genesis chapter 6 verse 3 we read
and the Lord said my spirit shall not
always strive with man for that he also
is flesh yet his days shall be 120
years.
So Noah preached for 120 years. Now it's
interesting that this
this number 120 occurs quite regularly
in the Bible
and one wonders whether it has any
additional meaning.
In Genesis chapter 6 verse 7 it says
and the Lord said I will destroy man
whom I have created from the face of the
earth both man and beast and the
creeping things and the fowls of the air
for it repenteth me that I have made
them. So
there was going to be a judgment.
And then the judgment came. God said
unto Noah in verse 13 the end of all
flesh is come before me for the earth is
filled with violence. That's a very
important point. Through them and behold
I will destroy them with the earth.
Make thee an ark of gopher wood. Rooms
shall thou make in the ark and shall
pitch it within and without with pitch.
So
there is a way of escape. And this was
the ark. And if you were in the ark
then you had followed the way of escape.
How many people were in the ark? Eight.
Eight.
Now you know it's interesting when you
go into biblical numerology
then eight the number eight is often
associated with with Jesus
because uh
if you want to look at it he was
resurrected on the first day which is
actually the eighth day in the cycle.
And there there are many many places and
there are many many books on numerology
you can study it uh
I don't go into it in great detail but
the number eight is associated with
Jesus and the number six is associated
with the arch enemy of Jesus, right?
So maybe the number eight just a
speculation
uh is those that are in Christ
for the end time if we apply it. So not
just eight people at the end but those
that are in Christ. Just a just a
thought. So you know this idea of 120
years is also fascinating. So Noah
preached for 120 years
and after the 120 years there was a
judgment.
And
those that were violent
were destroyed in the flood and only
those that were safe in the ark
were saved.
Now it's interesting that Moses was also
120 years old
when
the children went into Canaan.
And the Canaanites were dispossessed
and Moses died
and was resurrected
because he went to heaven because he
appeared
to Jesus and the disciples on the mount
of transfiguration.
So there was a special resurrection and
we read about it in the book of Jude
where there was this conflict with the
devil over the body of Moses.
So here again in Moses' case it was 120
years and then you have the 120 occurs
many times in the Bible. The 40 40 days
and the 40 days cycles and the 40 year
cycles and uh all of these they always
or tended to come in threes. So 40 40 40
is also 120. Now some of the Adventist
pioneers
uh had the idea that this might be a
reference also to the end of time
because if they calculated that if you
take 120 jubilees you get to 6,000
years. Just a Himes for example had
calculations like that. But we we won't
go into those details now. But just
interesting that there are these
interesting correlations. But the point
we are making here
is was there a time of judgment for the
antediluvian world? Yes.
Does the world today believe that there
was a universal flood?
Mostly no. No. In fact science says
there was no universal flood but this
nice fossil here on this table
tells us that there was a universal
flood.
Because the fossil world is buried in
watery graves.
In fact fossilization needs very special
circumstances
and they need water for the exchange of
the minerals to take place. So, this is
not the original ammonite,
this fossil. This is a mineralized
copy of it, in other words.
But, it doesn't take millions of years
for these things to happen.
And then you have, of course, also these
chalk layers which are foraminifera
unicellular organisms and radiolarians
which are also deposited out of water.
So, the whole world must have been
covered in water because this is a
universal layer. So, there was a
universal flood and God
destroyed humanity in the past and only
those that were in the ark were saved.
Now, these serve as a type for the end
of time.
So, my next question would be
did God really say that this judgment
was a type of the final judgment? And if
we go there to 2 Peter chapter 2 verse
5,
he says, "And he spared not the old
world, but saved Noah, the eighth
person, a preacher of righteousness,
bringing in the flood upon the world of
the ungodly and turning the cities of
Sodom and Gomorrah into ashes, condemned
them with an overthrow, making them an
example unto those that after should
live ungodly."
This is quite a mouthful.
So, you have two typologies here.
You have the destruction of the
antediluvian world
in the days of Noah, which serve as a
type of the final judgment.
And Noah was a preacher of
righteousness.
The righteousness of Christ is going to
be a central part of the final message.
How are you saved?
You're saved by the righteousness of
Christ, right?
No works. What was the way of Cain?
Works. Works.
And Babylonian religion, what was that?
Also. It was works.
So, this was the unique religion
where you were not saved by your merits,
but you were saved by an alien merit, as
Martin Luther put it. A merit which was
not part of you, but which came from a
higher source, Jesus Christ. And these
two religious systems have been in
conflict since Cain and Abel. Since Cain
and Abel.
Now, the fascinating thing is
that even those that were in the truth
and believed that the lamb was the way,
even they, over time, tended to revert
back to the Babylonian system. So, you
might have the truth for a while and
then the sad apostasy comes into
the people of God and eventually they
decay and become part of Babylon again.
So, there's this constant
constant cycle and every time that they
move away, God sends a prophet.
And he brings them back and then they
fall away and then God sends a prophet
and he brings them back. And it's just a
constant ebb and flow.
Are we going to have the same
at the end?
And then he gives this striking example
of the cities of Sodom and Gomorrah that
were destroyed by fire and brimstone.
And this serves as a type again for
those that should live ungodly at the
end of time.
So, in other words, there was a flood
and there was a judgment.
Here's the evidence.
This creature is extinct, this ammonite.
There were many, many creatures that
lived before the flood
that don't exist anymore. In fact, this
is one of the arguments
that negates the evolutionary theory.
Because if evolution was right, you
would have to start with a very low
density of animals
and you would have to get more and more
and more variety as you continue. But,
in fact, we have a reverse. We have a
large number of creatures in the past
and we're getting fewer and fewer as we
go along.
So, we have a reversal there
which shows that there must have been a
massive
creation with huge variety of animals,
many of them being extinct. So, the
fossils
are not an evidence of evolution, but
evidence of a much greater diversity in
times past. There's another point.
The the size is reversed. If evolution
is correct,
then you should evolve from small to
large.
So, obvious thing, you don't start
evolution with an elephant and end with
an amoeba.
You start with an amoeba and end up with
an elephant at the end, right?
But, everything was bigger and greater
in the past and more
degenerate today and smaller.
So, yes, there was a destruction in the
past and God really said there would be
a judgment.
And we drive our vehicles
with the evidence of that judgment.
Where does all this organic matter come
from
that is hidden in the bowels of the
earth?
It's organic matter.
It must have been
alive. alive at some stage.
So, when they went into the ark,
then God promised them that he would no
longer destroy the world with a flood.
The final destruction will be with fire,
right?
Genesis 9:15,
did they believe God when he said, "And
I will remember my covenant which is
between me and you and every living
creature of all flesh and the waters
shall no more become a flood to destroy
all flesh."
There might still be local flooding,
but there won't be a universal flood.
Genesis 11 verse 4 said, "And they
said," these are the Babylonians,
remember we're working towards the
Babylonian mindset and thinking.
"Go, let us build us a city and a tower
whose top may reach unto heaven and let
us make us a name,
lest we be scattered abroad upon the
face of the whole earth." They actually
built the tower
to overcome a future flood.
So, they did not believe God.
The point that I'm trying to make is
that humanity has this tendency
not to believe what God really said.
And if you don't believe what God really
said, then what do you actually believe?
It's a very important point.
So, did God really send Moses to deliver
the people when they were in Egypt?
Well, in Exodus 2 verse 14, we read
and he said, this is now the Israelite
that was being assisted and helped by
Moses,
"Who made thee a prince and a judge over
us?
Intendest thou to kill me as thou
killest the Egyptian?" And Moses feared
and said, "Surely this thing is known."
They didn't realize that Moses was going
to be a prince and a judge over them.
And he serves as a type of a greater
prince and a greater judge who they also
rejected, which is Jesus, right?
So, what I'm pointing out here is
do people really believe when God sends
someone
to be the prince and the judge?
The answer is no.
How much unbelief is there in the world?
Did God really require a change of
lifestyle
when he
brought the children of Israel out of
Egypt?
Numbers 11:6 says, "But now our soul is
dried away, there's nothing at all
beside this manna before our eyes."
We've dealt with this, so I'm not going
to go into details.
God's answer, "And they went forth a
wind from the Lord and brought quails
from the sea and let them fall by the
camp as it were days' journey on this
side and as it were a days' journey on
the other side around about the camp and
as it were two cubits high upon the face
of the earth and the people stood up all
that day and all that night and all that
next day and they gathered the quails."
"He that gathered least gathered 10
homers and they spread them all abroad
for themselves around about the camp."
And we've discussed it before,
but God was not pleased with them.
Psalms tells us they lusted exceedingly
in the wilderness and tempted God in the
desert. My point is that whatever God
does,
human nature rebels against it, even
though it is for your own good, right?
So, he gave them their request, verse
15,
but he sent this leanness, this
emptiness into the soul.
And then again in Corinthians, we read,
"Now, these things were our examples to
the intent we should not lust after the
evil things as they also lust.
So, all of these things in the Old
Testament served as a type
for God's people.
And every time
if God said something
you can ask the question that you've
been asking the whole time. They were
asking, "Did God really say?" I don't
think he meant it. No.
I don't I don't think he wants us to do
this to do this. No, no, no.
Do I really have to do this? Do I really
have to believe this? No, God is not
going to do this, right?
So, did God really say that his people
should separate themselves from the
world? This is a very complicated one.
Very hard for people.
Let's go to the Old Testament because
we're we're looking at type and
antitype, right?
Now, the Lord had said unto Abraham,
"Get thee out of thy country and from
thy kindred and from thy father's house
unto a land that I will show thee."
Out of your country,
away from your family,
even away from your father's house.
Come out.
Now, that's a a very important call.
There were two calls to Abraham.
The one was in in Ur and the other one
was in Haran.
And if we go
to the New Testament, there are two
calls in the book of Revelation
about Babylon.
Yes.
Revelation chapter 14, you have Babylon
is fallen.
The second
And then Revelation chapter 18, you have
Babylon is fallen.
Come. Come out.
So, it's a very similar thing.
So, type and antitype
have to meet each other.
So, Jesus himself reiterates this and
says in Matthew 19:29,
"And everyone that has forsaken houses
or brethren
or sisters." Here's your family.
"Or father or mother or wife or children
or lands for my name's sake shall
receive a hundredfold and shall inherit
everlasting life."
This is not an instruction to
avoid your family.
And to sell everything now and No.
Definitely not. This is an instruction
to separate yourself because we're
living in the antitype.
To separate yourself from that which is
against God. You have to come out of
that mindset.
And anything that's clinging you to the
world. Yes. Get rid of that. Nothing
must stand in your way
with your relationship.
other words, not your father,
nor your mother,
nor your wife, nor your children, or
anything that you own should keep you
from following the truth. You must love
all of them, but your love for God is
the
main Absolutely. Absolutely.
So, did God really say that his people
should separate themselves from literal
Babylon? So, we're going back to ancient
times and then we'll come to the modern
times, right?
Because
this this type and typology and antitype
is is fascinating in the Bible.
Isaiah 48:20,
now, this is quite a while before this
Babylonian takeover.
He said, "Go ye forth of Babylon, flee
ye from the Chaldeans. With a voice of
singing declare ye, tell this, utter it
even to the ends of the earth. Say ye,
The Lord has redeemed his servant
Jacob." Babylon is an obstacle to those
who want to be part of God's plan. Yes.
It's an obstacle.
So, it has to do with salvation because
it's redemption here, right?
So, you have to flee from the Babylonian
mindset. Here was a literal fleeing from
the Babylonian.
Don't become involved with Babylonian
thinking.
And then Jeremiah in the time when
Babylon actually conquered
Jerusalem. He says, "Flee, get ye far
off, dwell deep, oh ye inhabitants of
Hazor, says the Lord, for
Nebuchadnezzar, king of Babylon, has
taken counsel against you and has
conceived a purpose against you." So,
this mighty king
of Babylon, the one who was the one who
took the Israelites captive.
Yes.
He has a couple of attributes. He took
counsel against God's people.
And he has conceived a purpose against
you.
So, he doesn't leave you alone, does he?
for you. He's going to come for you.
Uh what is his purpose in coming for
you? To take you. He wants to conquer
you. He wants to take you captive.
He wants you to be his servant.
Yes.
So, he has a a problem with anyone who
doesn't worship according to his style.
Did he enforce his way of worship? Yes.
What happened to Daniel's friends? Did
they have to bow down? Yes. And did they
refuse? Yes. They refused, correct?
So, Jeremiah 51:6
says, "Flee out of the midst of Babylon
and deliver every man his soul. Be not
cut off in her iniquity."
For this is the time of the Lord's
vengeance. He will render unto her a
recompense.
So, Babylon will be judged.
And if you are part of Babylon, you will
be judged together with Babylon.
So, when literal Babylon
is destroyed,
that serves as a type for antitypical
Babylon. And if you are part of
antitypical Babylon, you will be
destroyed together with it. So, you have
to come out of it.
You have to
Literally. You have to come out of
Babylon. Literally and mentally.
Yes, absolutely.
So, now let's go and ask ourselves this
question then. If that was the type,
where's the antitype?
Did God really say that his people
should separate themselves from
antitypical Babylon?
Now, we're coming to our day. Yes. Let's
read the verses. Revelation 18. This is
the loud cry.
"And after these things I saw another
angel come down from heaven having great
power and the earth was lightened with
his glory." This is a message that has
to go
out universally. It's not a conspiracy.
It's a message from God.
Yes.
"And he cried mightily with a strong
voice saying, 'Babylon the great is
fallen, is fallen.'"
Now, how many times does he say it
there? Twice.
He says it twice.
"And is become the habitation of devils
and the hold of every foul spirit and a
cage of every unclean and hateful bird."
When literal Babylon fell, there was a
writing on the wall and it said, "Mene,
mene." Yes. They were also twice.
Because there was of course
uh
the two kings ruling.
It was Belshazzar and it was his father
and his father had taken care of the
spiritual side and he had taken care of
the political side.
So, it was a union of church and state.
So, there were two aspects to literal
Babylon, the church and the state and
they worked together.
And here again you have the two aspects.
Babylon is fallen, is fallen. There's a
spiritual aspect and there is a
political aspect.
And it has become a habitation of devils
and the hold of every foul spirit. There
is a false Holy Spirit in this
system.
And a cage.
What is a cage? Something that keeps you
captive, right?
Yes.
Of every unclean and hateful bird. So,
here are false spirits. Because the true
spirit of God is depicted as a dove. So,
an unclean bird, every foul unclean,
hateful bird is a false spirit. So, this
is demons.
But then you have these sad words that
all nations
"have drunk of the wine of the wrath of
her fornication."
So, they all drank Babylonian wine. Mhm.
What does wine stand for?
Doctrine. Doctrine. So, they've
swallowed Babylonian doctrine.
"And the kings of the earth have
committed fornication with her." So,
here you have the two aspects. You have
the wine of Babylon, which is false
doctrine. This is the ecclesiastical
side.
And then you have the political side,
which is the kings of the world. So, you
have the two. Yes.
They were all as part and parcel of
Babylon.
But there's another one mentioned over
here and that's the merchants of the
earth.
Now, if you go back to the Old
Testament, there were also the
merchants. The king of Tyre also served
as a type. merchant, was very important
there.
And the earth or waxed rich through the
abundance of her delicacies.
So, there's money in Babylon. Yes. She
controls the economy.
And I heard another voice from heaven
saying, and hear those words again,
"Come out of her, my people, that you be
not partakers of her sins, and that you
receive not of her plagues."
For her sins have reached unto heaven,
and God has remembered her iniquities.
Iniquities, they are against God's law
and against against God's word. Mhm.
So, at the end of time, we have a system
which is called antitypical Babylon.
It consists of a union of church and
state.
Mhm. It has false doctrine. It controls
the economy.
And you have to separate yourself from
them.
That's very hard.
Because there's an
economic implication.
There's a religious implication.
And there's a political implication.
Yes.
Very hard.
Now, who is Babylon?
We need to know. Definitely.
You can't say to someone come out of
Babylon and not say what Babylon is,
right? If you don't have a definition,
how would you know? Exactly. So,
let's have a look at the three
components of Babylon. It's also called
the city. Babylon was a city.
Revelation 16:19, "And the great city
was divided into three parts." So, we
know that Babylon has three components.
Besides being church and state, there
are three other aspects. Yes.
"And the cities of the nations fell, and
the great Babylon came into remembrance
before God
to give unto her the cup of the wine of
the fierceness of his wrath."
"And I saw," in verse 13, "three unclean
spirits
like frogs."
Now, frogs were very important Egyptian
deity. Yes.
And they were worshipped.
And one of the plagues was the plague of
frogs, right?
"Came out of the mouth of the dragon
and out of the mouth of the beast, and
out of the mouth of the false prophet."
So, those are the three components.
There's the dragon component.
Yes.
There's the beast component. And there's
the false prophet component.
And Jesus warned there would be many
false prophets.
So, the false prophet again is divided
into many groups called many false
prophets.
Now, the beast was identified by the
Reformation very clearly, even in
pre-Reformation times,
as the Roman Catholic system. Mhm.
The dragon is associated with
the religion of the dragon. In other
words, spiritism in all its
manifestations.
And the false prophet you find in
Revelation chapter 13
is associated particularly with the
second beast of Revelation chapter 13.
And that is
Protestantism that has reverted back to
the Babylonian principles.
Yes.
So, those three components.
So, all the world's religions will fall
into one of these three categories.
"For they are the spirits of devils
working miracles, which go forth unto
the kings of the earth and of the whole
world to gather them to the battle of
that
great day of God Almighty."
So, there's going to be a conflict Mhm.
between the mindset of Babylon and God's
people.
Okay.
And who's going to be involved
on the Babylonian side?
The kings of the earth.
Everybody in the world will be
influenced by this, so you have to make
a
choice.
And there will be a conflict.
"Behold, I come as a thief. Blessed is
he that watches and keepeth his
garments, lest he walk naked, and they
see his shame." Here again, you have
this
illusion to
nakedness.
The robe of righteousness should cover
you.
Yes.
So, here you have righteousness by
faith. Remember Noah was a preacher of
righteousness?
Mhm.
And Abel accepted righteousness by faith
in the blood of the lamb. And Cain
refused to accept it.
"And he gathered them together into a
place called in Hebrew tongue
Armageddon, mountain of Megiddo, where
the great conflict between the priests
of Baal took place." Mhm. And here is
this massive conflict. So, this is
steeped in Old Testament typologies.
Yes.
The great conflict at the end of time.
And we need to understand this
because our life depends on it. We have
to make a choice where we stand.
Now,
I said that the reformers had identified
the beast as Catholicism. Now, let me
make it quite plain.
We're talking about a system. We're not
talking about people. Mhm.
People have to make individual choices.
And just because a system is defined as
being part of Babylon, and we will see
why, doesn't make the people Babylonians
necessarily, because they could be
deceived, right?
So, Bible The Bible tells us quite
clearly that God says, "Come out of
her." Who?
My people.
My people. So, where are God's people
largely situated? In that system. In
that system. But they have to come out.
Now,
Catholics are very sincere believers.
And if you take the great reformers in
the Reformation, they were all Catholic.
Yes. And yet they became the great
reformers, like Martin Luther and
Melanchthon and what they were all
called, right?
So, we're not talking about individuals.
This is not an attack
on anyone that is a Catholic. It is a
exposition of the system. What is wrong
with the system?
I mean, after all, I was a Roman
Catholic, but I'm no longer a Roman
Catholic because I've recognized that
the system
is not in harmony with God's word. Yes.
So, we'll have to look at that.
Now,
here is a book
that was written in 1946,
and it comes from Moody Press. So,
this is a beautiful little book. It's a
very thin little book. And if you look
it up on Amazon,
you can see that it can go for an
exorbitant price. Okay. Because it's
basically out of print, right?
Yeah.
But
uh this was in 1946, and I found it very
fascinating to see what the Moody Press
had to say about uh this issue. The
Bible and the Roman Church.
"The reformers regarded the Holy
Scripture as the sole rule of faith and
practice.
And the sons of the reformers throw the
sole rule out of the window."
That's interesting.
Yes.
"Torn to shreds by the deft impious
hands of the critic.
With the Bible goes the God of the
Bible.
And when we charge Rome with a literal
idolatry for her veneration of images,
relics, and so forth, she comes back
with an accusation of intellectual
idolatry
in that Protestantism, having rejected
the God of revelation, has created a new
God, the product of apostate thinking."
Now,
this is not an Adventist source. This is
Moody Press. They realize that there are
many, many people,
thousands,
living in Protestant churches who
realize where the problem lies.
Why they have become the product of
apostate thinking.
And why, as a consequence, they've
actually aligned themselves with Babylon
and become part of the Babylonian
system.
Do you remember that document we
discussed the other day? Yes. Jubilee
for the Earth. Jubilee for the Earth.
Isn't it incredible how steeped in
Babylonian wine that document is?
Yes. It's actually comes forward as if
it's not a Protestant document. As if it
was written by one of them. And how many
people are sitting
in Protestant churches today,
and they look at the morality that is
being proposed, and they look at the the
doctrines, how they're being
reinterpreted,
and they are literally devastated. Some
of them are in tears.
Mhm.
But they don't know where to go.
And so, they're stuck in the system.
They're stuck in the system.
a new thing. This was in 1946 Moody
Press already realized this.
So they've created a new God, the
product of apostate thinking. Rome is
not afraid of modernism.
It is a fruitful fishing pool.
Because the human heart cannot be
satisfied with the vague, vaporous,
uncertainties of modernism. Rome
addresses herself to those who are under
the influence of that emasculated brand
of Protestantism.
And offers the authority of the church
founded by Jesus Christ in place of the
bewildering uncertainties of
indifferentism.
It's brilliantly put.
Mhm.
So here comes Rome and says, you know,
you are a ship adrift upon an ocean with
nowhere to go.
Because you have given up on the
principles of the Bible, you've attached
yourself to modernism. And now look at
you, your morality has gone out of the
window, you have no anchor. Come to
Mother Church.
Mhm. And I will give you an anchor.
So then your affiliation has to shift
from the God of the Bible
to a person who claims to be the
representative of God here on earth.
Yeah, it's a very dangerous um thing to
be like it stated there
um Rome is not that doesn't um distance
itself from modern modernism. No, it
doesn't.
It embraces it. Because in that way it
can uh grab more. Uh-huh.
It continues and he he writes here
all this has to do with modernism.
What about our evangelicalism?
We profess the supreme authority of God
and of His word. But how does it work
out in our lives?
It is not only possible, but all too
common to be evangelical in doctrine and
modernist in practice.
Giving mental assent to the great
doctrinal tenets of the faith once
delivered to the saints and at the same
time refusing obedience to the standards
of the gospel living enunciated with
equal authority in the holy writ.
Everything goes, right?
Yeah. In Protestantism today everything
goes. There's no
rule as to diet, for example. There's no
rule as to dress or uh Anything more
Anything. Anything.
Any the way you worship even.
Now that doesn't mean that there are not
individuals who are doing the very best
they can to worship God according to His
principles.
What he believes is right. Yes. And they
are sighing and crying for all the evil
that is done in the world.
He continues, it is one thing to study
the scriptures for theological
exactness, another to submit to them for
the regulation regulating of one's life.
Dogmatically we acknowledge Christ Jesus
as Lord.
Which title we hold as the title of His
deity.
Then how can we yield other than
practical submission to Him as the Lord
of our lives and the God of our
salvation?
Now I like this because this is not an
Adventist and he's saying
you have to have an orderly life. You
have to live according to the
principles. Today if you say that
you're a fanatic. Yeah.
Full consecration and complete obedience
are only logical answer to our
profession as evangelicals.
Rome points to the modernist brand of
Protestantism as a fine example of that
scripture which says
in those days there was no king in
Israel.
And every man did that which was right
in his own eyes.
It's ours to demonstrate that there is a
king in Israel.
See, we want we want a savior, but we
don't necessarily want a king to rule
over us.
Mhm. A king has rules.
Yes. A king has laws.
So
Protestantism today
is a
fruitful fishing field for Rome.
Because there's no anchor.
Because they've given up on has God
really said these things? They don't
believe it anymore.
They don't believe that God really said
there was a flood. They don't believe
that God really said this, that, that,
and the other.
So then what do you believe?
Here's an interesting book
by Strom on the conscience and it's the
secularization of conscience.
And here's an abstract. Conscience was
emancipated from institutional religion
during the era of the enlightenment.
So we're separated.
And it is often thought that this was
due to secularization during that time.
Paradoxically it could be said that it
was the consequence of the 16th and 17th
century evangelical fervor.
That's an interesting statement.
Mhm.
The relationship between conscience and
organized religion did not end then
altogether.
It enjoys considerable support in
institutionalized
Christianity.
The divine presence still exists quite
strongly in the notions of conscience.
The secularization of conscience
examines how conscience drifted from its
strong Christian ties
and became unchurched.
And was adopted by 18th century
philosophers.
Enlightenment philosophers rejected a
narrow conception of conscience and
opened its deliberations to larger
horizons of social consensus.
In other words, what he's saying
is that your conscience in the past used
to be dictated by your religious
convictions.
Mhm.
But now it has been emancipated from
your religious convictions
and your conscience is now being
dictated to by social consensus.
Mhm. So what is right and what is wrong
is not determined by the word of God.
It is not determined by your religion.
It is determined by your social
environment.
Yes. Very dangerous. Very, very
dangerous because where's your anchor?
You can go from one social environment
to another and be in a totally different
social crowd with totally different
norms. And we don't even have to go into
the details. People can think for
themselves, right? If some if in one
group something is acceptable it doesn't
necessarily make it right. Exactly.
So what is your basis for morality
according to the scripture?
Now here's a quote from the spirit of
prophecy. This is an Adventist view.
The great lesson book.
Study the word.
The word is the great lesson book for
the students in our schools. The Bible
teaches the whole will of God concerning
the sons and daughters of Adam.
The Bible is the rule of life teaching
us of the character we must form for the
future immortal life. Our faith, our
practice may make us living epistles
known and read of all men.
Men need not the dim light of tradition
and custom to make the scriptures
comprehensible.
It is just as sensible to suppose that
the sun shining in the heavens at
noonday needs the glimmering of the
torchlight of earth to increase its
glory.
The fables or the utterances of priests
or of ministers are not needed to save
the student from error.
Consult the divine oracle and you have
light. In the Bible every duty is made
plain, every lesson is comprehensible,
able to fit men for a preparation for
eternal life. So clearly the Bible is
the standard of morality. Yes.
Here's another quote.
The gift of Christ and the illumination
of the Holy Spirit reveal to us the
Father and the Son. The word is exactly
adapted to make men and women and youth
wise unto salvation.
In the word is the science of salvation
plainly revealed. All scripture is given
by inspiration of God and is profitable
for doctrine, for reproof, for
correction, for instruction in
righteousness. That the man of God may
be perfect, thoroughly furnished unto
all good works. Search the scriptures.
For therein is the counsel of God, the
voice of God speaking to the soul.
The word of God is the basis of
morality.
This is what Protestants used to
believe.
The word This is what Adventism teaches.
The word of God gets you onto that
higher plane. It gets you onto the
higher plane.
Youth, in the name of Jesus I appeal to
you my shall soon meet around the throne
of God. Study your Bible.
It will prove to you not only the pillar
of cloud by day, but the pillar of light
of fire by night.
It opens before you a path leading up
and still upwards bidding you go
forward. The Bible.
You do not know its worth. It is the
book for the mind, for the heart, for
the conscience, the will, and the life.
It is the message of God to you in such
simple style that it meets the
comprehension of a little child.
So, the Bible is the norm and the
standard.
Now, the official Bible of the Roman
Church is the Vulgate.
That was accepted by the Council of
Trent to be the only infallible Bible in
contrast to the Protestant Bible. So,
we're back to manuscripts, right?
Yes.
This comes from Moody Press, page 19.
And this is that same little book
by Macauley 1946, The Bible and the
Roman Church. And he writes,
"When the Vulgate was issued by Pope
Sixtus V to the accomplishment of
anathemas against any who would change a
word of it, it was so full of corruption
that it had to be withdrawn and revised.
And was reissued by Clementine VIII
still under the name of Sixtus."
Now, this is not an Adventist source
again. This is Moody Press. Yes.
So, the Vulgate was so full of
corruptions.
Now,
if you think about what has influenced
the mind of man to move away from a thus
says the Lord. There are so many isms.
Let's go some of them. The Origin of
Species. It's also interesting
when
they were released.
So, here is the introduction to the
Origin of Species and it says,
"The mystery of mysteries as it has been
called by one of our great
philosophers." So, Darwin says he
started thinking about it in 1837.
But he actually put it on paper in the
year 1844.
And then he sent it to everyone, and
then he finally wrote the book
after that. So, 1844 is the date in
which, according to the Origin of
Species, this book
was being conceived.
1844 is an interesting date, right?
And this this theory has done more than
many other theories to discredit the
Bible
and to
remove the faith of the believers from
the Bible.
Yes. And that's why we have all those
lectures on evolution. If people want to
look if you put the links in before, you
can put them again.
especially also your lecture on 1844,
the day that changed the world.
Correct. And also with Darwinism, even
if you didn't become an atheist, you've
got a lot of people that actually
believe. They're believers. They're
Protestants. You're you are Christian.
But then there's some portion that you
don't completely believe what God has
God said. Yes.
You
maybe say, "Okay, this
earth was created in six periods.
Correct.
But not literal days. So,
that the roots of Darwinism is actually
very deep.
Absolutely. And theistic evolution is
another major problem because theistic
evolution
leads you to the conclusion that death
is the mechanism for achieving greatness
through natural selection.
But according to the scripture, death is
a consequence of sin. So, there was no
death in the beginning, so it couldn't
have been a mechanism for evolution. So,
it totally negates the gospel.
So, is it interesting that in the same
year, 1844,
the Sinaitic manuscript Codex Sinaiticus
was discovered at Mount Sinai?
And if you look here, if we if we take
the text from the King James version of
Genesis 3:15,
which is based on the received text,
then it says, "And I will put enmity
between thee and the woman, and between
thy seed and her seed, and it shall
bruise thy head, and thou shalt bruise
these heel." This is the great promise
of redemption in Jesus Christ.
And the seed of the woman, of course,
between the seed of the woman, which is
the church, and the seed of the devil,
which is his church, and there will be
enmity between them until the end. And
the seed being singular, as Paul says,
will come, which is Christ, and he will
bruise or crush the head of the serpent.
And Christ will be
injured in the heel.
But if you take the Douay-Rheims, which
is the Jesuit version, which is the
Catholic counter to the Reformation
Bible, they put it this way, "I will put
enmities between thee and the woman, and
thy seed and her seed, and she
shall crush thy head, and thou shalt lie
in wait for her heel." So, they make it
a reference to Mary. So, now Jesus has
been taken out of the picture.
But clearly,
uh this is the way in which it should
have been put.
So, in other words, it is a masculine
form and not a feminine form.
What's also fascinating is on May the
8th, 1844. I mean, a lot of things
happened in that year, right? Yes.
The leader of the Roman Catholic Church,
Pope Gregory the XVI, sent a letter to
the members of the Catholic hierarchy
condemning the Bible societies
as basically enemies of Catholicism.
And argued against what he termed the
indiscriminate circulation of the
scriptures to lay people.
This letter was published in the New
York Herald on
July 15, 1844, and it reads in part as
follows, "Those Bible societies only
care audaciously to stimulate all to a
private interpretation of the divine
oracles,
to inspire contempt for divine
traditions,
which the Catholic Church preserves upon
the authority of the holy fathers."
So, if you read the Bible
and you interpret the Bible together
with the Holy Spirit, then according to
Rome, you are
deviating from her principles.
"The reading of the holy Bible
translated into the vulgar or common
tongue should not be permitted
except to confirm people in the faith.
No version whatever should be permitted
to be read, but those which should be
approved of the Holy See.
Accompanied by notes derived from the
writings of the holy fathers or other
learned Catholic authorities." So, Rome
tells you that only they will interpret
the Bible.
"We confirm and renew the decrees
against the publication, distribution,
reading, and possession of the books of
the holy scriptures
translated into the vulgar tongue."
Why don't have that problem anymore
today? That was in 1844. They had a
major problem. Why don't they have it
anymore? Maybe because the Holy See
approved
the new Bibles.
Uh-huh.
So, if you can
place contempt upon the Protestant
versions
and accept the Roman Catholic versions,
then you're fine, right?
Now, the Bible actually warns that there
will be an assault on the word.
Second Corinthians 2:17. There are a
number of verses here from Corinthians
and Jeremiah and and Peter. Let's read
some of them.
"For we are not as many as corrupt the
word of God." So, there will be people
that corrupt God's word.
Or handle the word of God deceitfully.
Or steal words out of the word of God.
Jeremiah, "I'm against the prophets,"
says the Lord, "that steal my words." In
other words, don't say what I've
actually said or change it.
Pervert the words of the living God.
Or Peter, "Rest as they do the other
scriptures." Take them out of context.
So, these are all
artful ways of the devil, right? "Has
God really said
it should be like this or like that?"
And which manuscript are you going to
use? Now, we've dealt with that, so
we're not going to deal with it again.
Or what about making the word of God of
none effect?
Darwinism, right? Oh, oh, yeah, there's
a story. It's an allegory. It's a little
fairy tale
about a flood and an ark and a this and
a that. Make it of none effect.
Or Romans 1:25, "Change the truth of God
into a lie."
Is that possible? Says you can take
God's word and change it into a lie.
Cast down the truth. This was one of the
attributes of the little horn power. It
cast down the truth to the ground, and
it practiced and it prospered. Was very
successful.
Well, we can see it's been very
Or Revelation 6:9, "And I saw under the
altar the souls of them which had been
slain for the word of God and for the
testimony which they held.
So, is there a war
around God's word?
Oh, definitely. Oh.
Could you be killed for it? Yes.
Have people been killed for it?
Millions. Millions. Can it happen again?
I think the Bible says it will. Ah.
So, obviously there's been a rebellion,
right? Against God's word.
Here's a statement from second selected
messengers.
I question whether genuine rebellion is
ever curable.
Study in Patriarchs and Prophets the
rebellion of Korah, Dathan, and Abiram.
This rebellion was extended including
more than two men. It was led by 250
princes of the congregation, men of
renown. Oh.
This makes me scared because type can
meet anti-type. Do you think we could
have people in our own midst, these are
the children of Israel,
who are in rebellion against God's word?
Or rebellion against the testimonies?
Could it be that there are
princes of the congregation, leaders in
the church that are
in this category?
We really have to question ourselves.
Men of renown.
Call rebellion by its right name and
apostasy by its right name and then
consider that the experience of the
ancient people of God with all its
objectionable features was faithfully
chronicled to pass into history.
The scripture declares, "These things
are written for our admonition upon whom
the ends of the world are come." 1
Corinthians 10:11. And if men and women
who have the knowledge of the truth are
so far separated from their great leader
that they will take the great leader of
apostasy and name him Christ our
righteousness,
it is because they have not sunk deep
into the minds of the truth.
They are not able to distinguish the
precious ore from the base material.
Oh, we dealt with a shaking.
There will be a shaking.
Because we have people in our midst that
don't believe the plainest statements in
the Bible.
And when you discuss the book of
Revelation, they call it a conspiracy
theory if you put it into the context of
modern times.
Yes.
I
If you use the modern or to the signs
happening all over us today, then you
will be labeled a conspiracy theorist.
You will be labeled a conspiracy
theorist.
I I
I like what one man says, "The only
person The only people who believe in
conspiracy theories are those of us who
have studied them."
Revelation 20:4, "And I saw thrones and
they that sat upon them and judgment was
given unto them and I saw the souls of
them that were beheaded for the witness
of Jesus and for the word of God."
This war
has been raging since the time of Cain
and Abel.
And this war will rage till the end of
time.
Now, what have these people done when
they come into conflict with what
system? Why should they be beheaded for
the witness of Jesus and the word of
God?
Because they refuse to worship the
beast.
Or his image.
Fallen Protestantism.
Church and state coming together.
Neither have received the mark upon
their foreheads, the mark of our
ecclesiastical powers that we've changed
the Sabbath, right?
And they lived and reigned with Christ
1,000 years.
The millennium.
Now, we've dealt with these before, but
just for the sake of clarity, let's put
them there again.
Now, what does Satan propose to do? He
proposes that he is capable of changing
this Bible.
These parties that fell understand all
about heaven.
And they can bring in the different
sentiments from the Bible and they are
going to have a revision of it. You will
see.
They will make revisions of the Bible,
but every one of us needs to stand
intelligently on the word. We cannot
afford to be careless, but we must have
that simplicity of godliness that is a
virtue to us. We must have it.
So,
I'm a bit scared of all these revisions
of the Bible. And I like the Protestant
Bibles based on the received text. So,
the old German Luther Bible, the German
Schlachter Bible, the old Afrikaans
translation in South Africa,
uh the King James version, or any
English Bible based on the received text
which with none of the Babylonian
changes in it.
Isn't it true that most of the
opposition that you we have been
receiving for the past 3 months
is in the interpretation that people get
from the Bible, but then uses modern
ones. Exactly. Well, we discussed that
for this the century. For example, you
you cannot even talk about it with the
new translation. It's so muddled.
It is the mind and character of the
persons who study the scriptures that
makes the study dangerous. The
difficulties will be removed from the
way
of those who search the scriptures with
earnest, humble hearts praying to the
Lord for wisdom.
Don't read into the Bible what your
preconceived ideas says.
There's to be no cutting out of
scripture, no mutilating of the words as
the Catholics have done. This is a very
plain statement.
The Bible is to be searched as a whole.
The thing in it hard to be understood
will become plain through the
enlightenment of the Holy Spirit.
Uh it doesn't say through the
enlightenment of the theologian. Yes. It
says through the enlightenment of the
Holy Spirit. Tyndale, in fact, said to
the theologians of his day
that he will make a plowboy Mhm. To know
more of the scripture.
Exactly.
Then
"Do you desire to destroy the covenant
between yourselves and your God? A
perpetual covenant means just what it
says. It is a sign between me and the
children of Israel forever," declares
God declares.
"For in 6 days the Lord made the heavens
and earth and on the seventh day he
rested and was refreshed."
This is our evidence.
"You will see ere long that there will
be those who will become weary of
hearing repeated the things they ought
to do, but do not desire to do and they
will change the wording of the Bible."
We know what the Lord says in Revelation
about those who do that. A perpetual
covenant is a perpetual covenant. You
can't change God's word.
Now, Rome has used its influence to
change the Bible. And even within
Protestant councils, they've placed
their influence there and they have
tried to change the Bible. I mean, read
the Douay Rheims which we read where
Mary will be the one that will crush the
head of the serpent. That is such a
blatant apostasy against the word of
God.
The Jesuits
are against the Protestant Bible.
And here is a quote from the Jesuits in
history
and it says, "This is the what the
Jesuits said about the Bible."
They said, "Then the Bible, that serpent
with its head erect and eyes flashing
threatens us, the Jesuits,
with its venom, while it's trails along
the ground, shall be changed into a rod
as soon as we, the Jesuits, are able to
seize it. For three centuries past, this
cruel asp has left us no repose.
You well know with what folds it
entwines us and what fangs it gnaws us."
They hate the scriptures.
And they don't base their theology on
the scriptures. Now, this is not just an
accusation.
This is not a conspiracy, either. This
is a fact.
Yes.
We can study what they write
and we can see.
So, to all our Catholic friends out
there,
this is no accusation against you as a
Catholic. This is a request.
Study your Bible and see if it
harmonizes what
with what the church teaches. And if it
doesn't,
then flee. Flee from Babylon. But this
is also
for the other Protestants. Absolutely.
With their If the Bible and their
versions of the Bible that they read.
Correct. If the Bible
don't even read the whole Bible. They
just want portions of the Bible.
So, the authority of the Holy Spirit
is replaced by the authority of man when
you take God out of the equation.
Cardinal Hosius, president of the great
Council of Trent, which is that council
where Protestantism and Catholicism
split, right?
Affirmed that apart from the authority
of the church,
the scripture would have no more weight
than the fables of Aesop.
That's quite a statement.
It comes from Wylie, The Papacy. So,
this is a very reputable source.
Mhm.
So, according to Rome,
the Bible has no authority whatsoever
unless it is interpreted by the church.
It's interesting that in uh Orthodox
Jewish circles, you have the same thing.
It has to be interpreted by the rabbis
because the layman hasn't got the right
to interpret the scriptures.
So, they support this position by
invoking 2 Peter 1:20, but they totally
ignore verse 21.
Because verse 20 says,
"Knowing this first, that no prophecy of
scripture is in any private
interpretation." So, they say, "Okay,
the church has to interpret it for you."
But verse 21 says, "For the prophecy
came not in old times by the will of
man, but holy men of God spoke as they
were moved by the Holy Ghost." So, who's
the interpreter? The Holy Ghost.
The Holy Ghost is the interpreter, not
the church.
Herein lies the answer to both the error
of private interpretation and the heresy
of
papal interpretation. Because you can
have a private interpretation, and
that's heretical. You're going to read
into it what you want,
and you can change the wording to take
out what is objectionable.
Matthew 11:28 says, "Come unto me, all
ye that labor and are heavy and laden,
and I will give you rest." Christ says,
"Come to me directly." Yes. You don't
have to go via a system.
Or verse 23 in John 14, Jesus answered
and said unto him, "If a man love me, he
will keep my words,
and my father will love him, and we will
come unto him and make our abode with
him."
So, what is your duty according to
Christ?
It doesn't say, "If a man love me, he
will follow the directives of the
church."
He says, "If a man love me, he will keep
my words." Where do I find these words?
In the Bible.
1 John 2:20,
"But you have an unction from the Holy
One, and you know all things." So, who
is your teacher?
God.
1 John 2:27, "But the anointing which
you have received of him abideth in you,
and you need not that any man teach
you." It's pretty clear.
"But as the same anointing teaches you
of all things, and is truth, and is no
lie, and even as it has taught you, ye
shall abide in him."
You don't need a human being.
Sometimes it's good to listen to advice
and to read what other people have said,
but in the final analysis, you have to
say to yourself,
"What is God saying?"
What is God saying? If you take the
Sabbath issue,
and you read in the Bible, "The seventh
day is the Sabbath of the Lord your
God,"
and the minister says, "We keep the
first day."
Is there a problem?
Did God really say? God really say?
So, now let's get to the nitty-gritty
and ask ourselves, what is the doctrine
of the serpent?
And what is the doctrine of devils that
we find in Babylon? Cuz it must be one
in the same, right? Mhm. So, we need to
understand what Babylon teaches, and we
need to separate ourselves from it. And
the criterion
must be the word of God. Yes.
Genesis chapter 3.
This is where we actually started.
"And now the serpent serpent was more
subtle than any beast of the field which
the Lord God had made, and it said unto
the woman, 'Yea, has God said, "Ye shall
not eat of every tree in the of the
garden?"' Here's that questioning.
And of course, the serpent wasn't
the subtlety. It was the one who was
using him as a medium, the devil
himself.
"And the woman said unto the serpent,
'We may eat of the fruit of the trees of
the garden,
but of the fruit of the tree which is in
the midst of the garden, God has said,
"Ye shall not eat of it, neither shall
ye touch it, lest ye die."
God is very fair, right?
He didn't put it in an obscure place. He
put it right there in the middle.
Confronted by choices.
Are we confronted by choices? Yes, every
day.
Absolutely.
Are they just sort of vague there
somewhere, or are they quite prominent?
Prominent.
"But the fruit of the tree which is in
the midst of garden, God has said, 'Ye
shall not eat of it, neither shall ye
touch it, lest ye die.'"
"And the serpent said unto the woman,
'Ye shall not surely die.'"
There's his first blatant contradiction
of God's word.
"For God knows that in the day ye eat
thereof, your eyes shall be opened, and
ye shall be as gods." There's his second
blatant contradiction.
You will be immortal. In fact, you will
be like God. And the third
contradiction,
you will know
good and evil.
You yourself will determine what is
right and what is wrong.
You don't need God to tell you what is
right and what is wrong. You will tell
yourself what is right and what is
wrong.
You will be totally independent. You
will be indestructible.
So, let's look at that first lie.
"Ye shall not surely die."
"And the Lord God formed man of the dust
of the ground, and breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life,
and man became a living soul." He didn't
receive a living soul. He became a
living soul.
So, the dust of the ground plus the
breath, the metabolism,
made him a living soul.
Now, you have to have both of these.
They must be the dust and the breath,
and that's a soul. There's not a soul
existing separately.
No. From this. So, you're either alive,
and you're metabolizing, you have a
respiratory
activity,
or you are dead.
"For the living know that they shall
die, but the dead know not
anything." Now, that's contrary to what
most people believe today. They think
that you are very wise up there and know
many things.
"But the dead know nothing. Neither have
they any more reward, for the memory of
them is forgotten."
The dead.
Isaiah tells us in chapter 26:19, "Thy
dead men shall live
together with my dead body shall they
arise. Awake, and sing, ye that dwell in
the dust, for thy dew is as the dew of
herbs, and the earth shall cast out her
dead." So, the Old Testament teaches
very plainly that when you die, you are
dust,
but there will be a resurrection.
And they will come up together. Together
with my dead body,
we will rise. So, there will be a death,
and there will be a resurrection.
Daniel confirms it and says, "And many
of them that sleep in the dust of the
earth shall awake,
some to everlasting life, and some to
shame and everlasting contempt." So,
there's a resurrection of life, and
there's a resurrection of death. So,
there's a judgment.
And death is called asleep.
Psalm 37:27,
"But the wicked shall perish."
"And the enemies of the Lord shall be as
the fat of lambs. They shall consume
into smoke. They shall consume away."
So, in other words, those that are
resurrected to receive eternal
damnation,
what happens to them?
Fire comes down, the Bible says in
Revelation, and consumes them,
and they will consume away. They will be
as though Nothing left. they never were.
Deuteronomy 5:25 says, "Now, therefore,
why should we die?
For this great fire will consume us."
Talking about the fire on Mount Sinai.
"If we hear the voice of the Lord our
God any more, then we shall die."
It's interesting that those who live in
the presence of God actually live in
that eternal fire.
Yes, they walk they in the fire.
And the devil turns it around. He's the
master of reversal.
He says the damnation is to live
eternally in the fire, and that is to be
damned. No, to be saved is to live
eternally in the fire.
Where did Lucifer, before he fell? He
walked amongst the fiery stones. What
about the three worthies? Yes. They
weren't consumed in the fire because
they were in the presence of God and God
protected them with his righteousness.
And there's beautiful symbolism in
Revelation to
of Jesus that also has fire in his eyes
and I think Yes, it's like burnished
brass.
yeah.
So, even Satan will be destroyed
according to the scripture. Ezekiel
28:18 says, "Thou has defiled thy
sanctuaries by the multitude of thine
iniquities
by the iniquity of thy traffic.
Therefore will I bring forth a fire from
the midst of thee.
It shall devour thee and I will bring
thee to ashes
upon the earth in the sight of all them
that behold thee."
So, the final destruction is by fire and
the consequences of this fire is
eternal. Now, now we're going to not
going to do a major Bible study on the
state of the dead, but you could perhaps
put a link in there.
As it is one of the pillars that we said
that is
we haven't spoken of, but we you've done
pretty much a good explanation of it now
and I'll also put some links
a more detailed one. I think it's called
the mystic realm of death.
I'll put that in the links.
But now, the point of this is to see
what does Rome teach? Mhm.
Now, here's the office of the catechism
and regarding this verse. Article 366 of
the catechism says, "The church, not the
Bible,
teaches that every spiritual soul is
immortal.
It does not perish when it separates
from the body at death."
The Bible says something else. Do they
know what the Bible says? It's important
that they say the church teaches that.
Here's the new Catholic Encyclopedia.
So, obviously they are aware of what the
Bible teaches.
And it says, "Human immortality, the
soul in the Old Testament means not a
part of a man, but the whole man as a
living being." That's exactly what the
scripture said. The dust plus
the breath, a man became a living being.
So, they know what the scripture
teaches.
Similarly, in the New Testament, it
signifies human life.
So, it's the human being.
The life of the individual conscious
object, the human being.
And then it talks about how they
interpret it. They've maintained that
the New Testament and new the recent
exegesis does not teach the immortality
of the soul
in the Hellenistic sense of survival of
an immortal principle of the dead.
So, the Bible doesn't teach what people
believe today.
That is actually a Greek philosophy that
there is a soul that separates from the
body
at death. Yes. So, the Roman Catholic
Church says, "We as a church teach that
you are immortal. You will not die.
We know that the Bible does not teach
it, but we prefer the Greek philosophy."
Yes, that's what's actually exactly what
they're saying.
That's what they're saying.
So, the Bible says one thing and they're
saying another thing. And they put it on
they have the authority because they are
the church. Okay. Now, what are they
believing? Are they believing the
serpent or they believing the word of
God? Serpent. It's the serpent theology.
Yes. Okay. Let's just make sure.
This is Pope Leo the 10th
who on Monday, December 19, 1513
issued a bull
declaring
"We do condemn and reprobate all who
assert that the intelligent soul is
mortal."
This bull was directed against the
growing heresy of those who denied the
natural immortality of the soul and
avowed the conditional immortality of
man.
Now, it's interesting that Martin Luther
himself
came to believe that when you die, you
sleep in the dust.
So, he was actually subject to this
bull.
It's also interesting that the Lutherans
today scrapped that belief of his. They
don't put it into their catechism.
So, what are they believing? They
believe immortality of the soul. So,
they believe what Rome teaches. So, is
that Babylonian doctrine or is that
biblical doctrine? Babylonian. It's
Babylonian. Okay.
Just to be clear, that means they
believe when you die, your soul still
lives on.
Yes.
Now, remember there's a dragon component
in the beast and we said that all
religions that have the dragon aspect,
in other words, what he teaches must
also have this belief. So, let's go to
spiritism.
Even early spiritist leaders admitted
that their communication was with Satan
himself.
In Spiritualist, a Norwegian spiritist
periodical, the following statement is
made.
"Spiritism is the serpent in paradise
offering man to eat of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil."
That's a very interesting statement.
Moses Hull, a leading spiritist lecturer
of that early time, makes the following
statement. "A truthful snake."
"In answer to the question, who then are
we to believe, God or Satan?
I answer,
the facts in every case in the Bible
justify us in believing Satan.
He has ever been truthful. This is more
than can be said of the other one.
It was not the devil, but God who made
the mistake in the Garden of Eden. It
was God and not the devil who was a
murderer from the beginning."
That's quite
stunning, right?
All right, this is pretty direct from
the spiritists. Comes from Spiritualist,
December 15, 1889.
And
another source is Facts of Faith, page
208. Now,
my question is this.
Uh in essence, what Rome teaches is
exactly the same. They don't spell it
out like this, but they believe the
serpent, right?
Yes, because the serpent said you will
surely not die.
And that's what they teach.
that's serpent theology.
Now,
what do the other major religions
believe?
They believe exactly the same thing,
right?
Okay.
It's interesting. Here's the house of
the Fox sisters where modern spiritism
was born. Yes.
It says, "The birthplace of modern
spiritism, upon this site stood
the Hydesville cottage, the home of the
Fox sisters
and
where the spirit world was established,
March 31, 1848.
There is no death. There are no dead."
So, that is basically the teaching, but
of course it started before 1848. Yeah.
Actually, if we go back in history,
Mother Ann Lee started off the Quakers
on the road to quaking.
The spirit world into the modern
society.
And they also denied the bodily
resurrection. This was an issue between
the Pharisees and the Sadducees, right?
And communicated with the spirits in
seance-type meetings and the time just
before 1844.
But in 1844, the rapping started in the
house that would be made famous by the
Fox sisters. So, again, we have that
date date, 1844.
So,
it seems as if Rome
and spiritism are on the same page when
it comes to the state of the dead. Yes.
And Protestantism? It's also gone over.
It's also on that same page. So,
the dragon,
the beast,
and the false prophet
all have this doctrine in common.
And if you separate yourself from that
doctrine and believe something else,
then according to them, you will be a
heretic.
And the Pope put it in an anathema,
right? So, he put it into one of his
decrees.
Now, let us go to the other ones, but I
think perhaps we should do that in a
further In a follow-up. In a follow-up.
Then we will do the others, which become
very interesting
where the issue is
that you will become gods, which is the
basis of the New Age movement.
And who's behind that New Age movement?
And then of course, the issue of
determining
for yourself
outside of scripture, what the basis of
morality is.
And when we understand
that these doctrines of the system are
totally contrary to the Bible,
then we can get a clearer understanding
of what constitutes the Babylonian
mindset and what it is that God's people
must separate from.
Yes, what do they have to come out of?
Thanks. So, till the next episode.
Will you pray for us?
us.
Our heavenly Father, thank you so much
for the blessings that we can receive
from you. We ask that you bless all of
us and keep us till the next episode. In
Jesus' name. Amen.
Thank you for watching this video.
To subscribe, click here. When the bell
appears, click and you will receive
notifications. To watch the next one,
click here.
Thank you again and see you next time.